téléski télésiège télécabine difficile
aujourd'hui d'imaginer dévaler les
pentes sans ses remontées mécaniques
même si leur maîtrise demande parfois un
peu d'entraînement dans les années 30 le
tourisme hivernal s'installe en france
pour rejoindre les cimes enneigées les
stations investissent alors dans des
remonte pentes et certains étaient
parfois assez insolite le thé les autos
ski un gros traîneau de treuils et
surtout de moteurs d'avions rolls royce
8 cylindres en étoile à cette même
période le transport par câble se
développe aussi dans les stations de
sports d'hiver
les téléskis et les télécabines commence
alors à habiller la montagne en 1943 les
travaux du troisième tronçon du
téléphérique de l'aiguillé du midi était
en cours
[Musique]
à 1650 m voici le futur terminus de la
ligne où sera construit l'hôtel le plus
haut d'europe ainsi qu'en laboratoire
pour l'étude des rayons cosmiques
ce téléphérique est encore aujourd'hui
l'un des plus hauts du monde mais de
telles innovations inclus 1966 cette
skieuse déplorait leurs prix trop élevé
il fera bien que dans la station puisse
prendre un forfait collectées qui nous
permet de prendre toutes les remontées
mécaniques quoi fin dans la journée même
pour 15 jours pendant la durée du monde
depuis les forfaits remontées mécaniques
se sont largement généralité en 1994 une
petite station familiale suisse
proposait même un forfait au point du
skieur en bas des pistes vous découvrez
la partenaire de vos vacances celles
dont dépend votre budget la balance il
faut se poser c'est vrai c'est vrai on a
lu ça en est on apprend ce thème blague
que c'est vrai l'année prochaine à
grächen le syndicat d'initiative ans
organiser des séjours à la taille
aujourd'hui près de 4000 remontées
mécaniques sont recensés sur tout le
domaine skiable français
[Musique]